my name is Damon Clark and I'm a
neuroscientist the central question in
Neuroscience is how does the brain work
I study vision and what I really love
doing is designing visual stimuli that
allow us to test very specific
hypotheses about how the brain works
that's sort of one of the joys I think
in lab is is doing that sort of design
work we study this in the fruit fly
drosophila the mathematical processing
that's happening in our brain and in the
fly's brain is really quite similar we
have designed virtual reality devices
for flies these are very small virtual
reality devices that have screens on
three sides and then we pin the fly in
place and suspend it over a little ball
so it walks on this treadmill and then
we can monitor how the fly is walking in
response to various visual stimuli
what's cool about drosophila is that we
can actually use genetics to manipulate
their brain we can turn different parts
of the brain on or off to see how those
affect the fly's Behavior
The Hope here is that we're studying
flies but we're also going to learn
principles that will apply to humans and
other animals what's fun to be able to
do is be able to connect individual
proteins in single cells move from
single cells to collections of connected
cells and then to whole regions of the
brain and then to behavior
that ability to make these connections
between different levels of
understanding is what's sort of really
powerful in neuroscience and what's
really exciting right now
[Music]